it's a great day because we've got the
backstreet boys and
in sync together what is life that i can
say that first of all
it's officially back sync thank you
thank you yeah i was gonna let you say
it it's 20 21.
it's a whole new everything yeah see i
gotta i gotta say something about the
back sink right off the bat though
what about sink back because we're
sinking back in time
that's that's not bad there's also
synthetic street six streets at six
minutes
end street there's open boys so many
it started as a group text and then it
became a thing so you know we'll see
yeah it is a thing and now you guys are
going to be taking the stage tonight
together
how do you feel about that so excited so
i mean we've all worked together in some
way shape or form
individually mean they could work
together obviously i mean aj lance is
working working with nick now
lance has done things with aj so it's
kind of cool to see the four of us
together and kind of do this and of
course
with you know being here for the trevor
project with being pride with raising
money doing all that stuff
you know for us it's kind of cool
because you know it's just like lgbtq
community coming together with everyone
so is in sync and factory board yep yep
they're always my favorite backstreet
boys
you guys do stuff i love it
[Applause]
[Music]
aj you mentioned that your kiddos are
here to support
what does that mean to you to know that
your kids are going to be in the
audience
watching their dad and his friends do
their thing
they're ecstatic my oldest is a
she obviously first a die hard
backstreet boy fan
she's converted a little bit lately and
is uh
choreographing and rocking out to these
guys
all day so my my house is either
billy eilish taylor swift or in sync
right now literally my michael
knew all the lyrics i wanted that way
and i was like where did you hear that
film
[Applause]
[Music]
but there's no badging boys there's no
rivalry we're all friends now they're
never we've always been yeah
i never like to say we're the only ones
that have lived that life together like
parallel lives but separate in a way so
when we have conversations with each
other we're the only ones that can
understand each other yeah
with that being said i was going to ask
what has it been like to be able to
develop a friendship over the years that
has led you all
now here tonight well it's great because
after a while i'm like so
how was how was it how did things go
with you and then we
started comparing legit comparing notes
like as far as like again same things
are parallel
to what we did yeah the funniest thing
ever though is when we did the
the sci-fi movie yeah me and how we were
hanging out mostly me and how he became
buds
and being how we were like how was like
so how did you guys really get to like
he had no idea how we really got
together like the true story
so we sat there and we we talked about
it which was fun playing that game in
your room
almost every night too that weird phone
clip whiplash whiplash yes so do you
guys have
like if you if we look in your imessages
is it like a backstreet boys
text group and then an in-sync text
group and then one together
we created one yeah and it has a nice
rainbow
that's where the name came from we might
add the other guys at some point but
right now we're having fun
i don't think we need to i think this is
good even even numbers are good right
you said that there's a joint backstreet
boys in sync album first off is that
real you said that
wait when did i say that no no no no
yeah i said i said that we're you know
maybe cooking something up
this could be something maybe i don't
know i mean look we're cooking
we're definitely cooking there's been a
lot of a lot of
positive feedback from the fans
thinking that this because look a lot of
fans for the last almost 30 years have
wanted to see this happen
right in any level whether it's all 10
of us or
four of us whatever that is and now that
it's happening
even if it's just one time i don't know
this may not be just you know what i
don't
know
i haven't said this might be something
that we can do every time for pride
so it's basically we're a group together
in that sense
every time pride is to support i mean
again who knows
so it's safe to say that a possible
joint
vsb in sync album is not off the table
it could be
interesting they keep asking well we'd
have to ask the other guys to get the
rights because you know there's little
parts that called you know we'd have to
figure out we may have to call the group
something completely different yeah
right back sync yeah like
think back think back backstage i do
believe like if
we ever we have done some collaborative
tours before
we did some stuff with the new kids on
the block and and that was really a lot
of fun for
the fan base as well you know different
generations but you know i think that if
we did
an album or of something like that it
would follow up with a tour it would
follow up with like this
huge thing with that being said with the
ideas is
there new music in terms of are you guys
creating anything original no just like
just like nick said this is very organic
this is very new to us this is something
that we literally were like you know
what this this
this could work in some sort of degree
but we don't know what that is yeah so
we can't even give you i could be like
well you know next year
hey maybe the next pride will be uh
launching our debut
single yeah i know it might be an album
call pride and that's what we do every
year
see because one of my i mean one of my
questions was like if you guys did
approach
like an album together if you would want
to do
i know all the glasses i'd be the lead
i'll say this from my perspective and i
i it's it's so much fun to sing
somebody else's the same dance
i was a fan i was a fan a legit fan
and like digital get down is still one
of my all-time favorite records and it
was never a single it should have been i
might dismiss my opinion
but like you know obviously the songs
that were singles
i was a fan like i bought the albums i
listened to the music
so i know the words but he's right it's
nice to sing
something other than your own music yeah
it's with the guys that did it first
i did a show uh called joytonium friends
and i do this thing where because
obviously
it's getting back together i want to
perform i love to perform i do i want it
that way
i do it in in my in the show that i do
so i've seen you guys do i went that way
together oh
we've gotta i've done i wanted that way
50 000 times
prepared for this performance yeah nick
you've told us actually you told ichi
recently that your favorite song of
theirs is i want you back
yes lance what's your favorite song i
always say the call
the call wow
yeah i love that one dirty pie baby
let's go
life and when is yep gonna fade out
really good editing in that video
yeah because you were injured i was i
was i'll never forget i'll never forget
listening to dirty pop the first time
i'm going
god damn why didn't we get this dude i
said the same thing i'm like
there was a lot of their songs there was
a lot of their songs
where i'm like yo max really like what
what i mean come on dude like we were
doing the same thing i was like
but yet they're just having a rivalry
so look you know back then there was no
social media there's none of that stuff
so the press and media then
pitted us against each other because
look same label
same management for a brief period of
time and we were all from orlando so
like
there was a lot of the parallels and we
were very similar same producers
yeah but there was still a difference
between the two of us you know and
but no i mean i've known joey for the
longest time yeah we live
down the street from each other we used
to hang out went to this guy's wedding
we have game night
him and michael are always hanging out
or we're going to their house i mean
there's a mutual response and i are
embarking on a business venture together
like right now some of my guys in my
group didn't even come to my 40th
he did all these years later how are the
dance moves
are you gonna tape are you gonna do
anything a little rusty take the show
you're gonna see yourself
yeah i mean i i mean look it's no secret
that i
was a horrible dancer back in the day
but i feel like i'm a way better
dancer now i think you really are really
good i think
you are actually yeah i think you're
better than better than you think yeah
and i'll say honestly and i know he can
relate and i believe you can relate
doing dancing with the stars since we
weren't on like yeah weren't on twitter
we all did that literally yeah
that literally changed my perception of
even the stuff that we do i know it's
more hip-hop and stuff like that
but yeah it made me stronger mentally
and it gave me the confidence i had
zero confidence in my dancing skills
until i did that show yeah
so tonight we're in for a treat you're
gonna see the geriatrics dance
yep it's gonna be great i love it you
guys thank you
so much congratulations on everything
personally professionally
as someone who has gone to multiple
concerts of both of y'alls
it's my kids and honors
there you go thank you so much